money a new ambitious climate target was
set by boris johnson this week for the
uk to have a fully green electricity
grid by 2035 and that's raised once
again the subject of nuclear power let
me just take you over to the data
dashboard briefly because you can see
that at the moment
13 of our electricity right now our
power right now is coming from nuclear
and that number is really pretty stable
now if he's going to meet his green
target does nuclear and the stability of
generation that it gives need to be part
of the mix donna carr put that question
straight to you
well the the fact is that we have to be
cutting our emissions by 2030 and if we
do even if we do decide to bid size
world c that won't be built until 2040
at the earliest and every single new
nuclear power station in europe over the
last 20 years has been 10 to 15 years
late so what we should be doing is not
going down an expensive white elephant
but investing in renewables and storage
and insulation
the total nuclear fleet produces only
five percent of britain's
energy needs it's a distraction from the
real concentration of energy efficiency
insulation renewables and storage well
okay okay and vicky what do you think i
mean greenpeace usa have said nuclear
energy has no place in a safe clean
sustainable future however it's
supporters would say it doesn't produce
co2 or greenhouse gases it's got a small
land footprint and it provides that
security of supply when the wind's not
blowing and the sun's not shining so
what's your take on it
i think we have been relying a bit on
nuclear and uh
the fact that if we leave things as they
are and we weren't building hinckley
point for example or we weren't thinking
of perhaps uh having size world c
uh nuclear uh power station um in
prospect then we would be probably
seeing the nuclear contribution reduced
very significantly over the next few
years uh nuclear has had a useful role
to play in the sense that it provided a
bit of that base load that you need
because renewables i'm afraid uh can be
very intermittent in terms of how they
produce that energy that you require
because it may not do the windmill blow
uh the sun may not shine so you lose
quite a lot of that but i think there is
an alternative if you're looking ahead
and that is we may need to be thinking
more about having that baseline provided
by other means rather than nuclear for
the future because nuclear is very okay
and briefly what would that be
it would be gas and we need to probably
have more gas fire power stations yes
but presumably that would produce
emissions wouldn't it so donald what do
you make of that we do we need we can't
just rely on renewables can we
no no
that's insane um to actually go down
propose new fossil fuel power plants
it's just
nonsense what we have to be doing is
actually looking at renewables and
storage
and tidal
and uh those three together if we invest
in them are cheaper than nuclear faster
than nuclear and reliable last month
five of the seven nuclear power stations
went down they're not as reliable as
people claim them to be renewables are
far cheaper storage is far cheaper green
hydrogen is far cheaper
you